♪ ♪
>> Jesse: IT'S TIME FOR THE
2020 ROUND UP, IF YOU THOUGHT
THAT DEMOCRATS EXTREME CLIMATE
AGENDA COULD NOT GET ANY
CRAZIER, THINK AGAIN.
HERE IS A NEW ONE.
IF YOU EAT MEAT OR USE PLASTIC
STRAWS, YOU ARE TO BLAME FOR
KILLING THE PLANET.
SO SAYS MAYOR PETE.
>> WE THINK ABOUT IT THROUGH THE
PERSPECTIVE OF GUILDS, FROM
USING A STRAW TO EATING A
BURGER, AM I PART OF THE
PROBLEM?
IN A CERTAIN WAY, YES, BUT THE
MOST EXCITING THING IS WE CAN BE
A PART OF THE SOLUTION.
>> Jesse: SO EXCITING, AND
THERE IS NEW YORK CITY'S
DISASTROUS
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO GOING
HEAD-TO-HEAD WITH TUCKER OVER
HIS CLIMATE HYPOCRISY.
>> HOW CAN YOU TAKE AN SUV TO
THE GYM AND BACK EVERY DAY AND
SAY THAT YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I KNOW IT IS A PETTY QUESTION.
>> IT IS A CHRYSLER PACIFICA.
IT IS A PACIFICA.
IT IS A HYBRID ELECTRIC, IT IS
NOT A GOOD SUV.
>> Jesse: BRIAN, IT IS A
PACIFICA.
>> Brian: BUT THE SUVs THAT
FOLLOW HIM, UNBELIEVABLE, I
THOUGHT IT WAS SO INTERESTING TO
SEE MAYOR de BLASIO.
ONE THING I GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR
IS GOING ON, MAYOR MACK TWO, HE
WON SUPPORTERS.
I THINK THAT NUMBER THREE WHEN I
LOOK BACK AT THE TAPE, I THINK
THAT --
>> Jesse: YOU WATCH HER
PERFORMANCE AFTERWARDS?
>> Brian: YES, MOST OF THE
TIME I GIVE MYSELF AN A+.
AND I EVALUATE MY APPEARANCE.
BACK TO MY ORIGINAL POINT, SEVEN
HOURS THAT, THAT MARATHON WAS
PROBABLY THE BEST THING THAT
HAPPENED TO TRUMP 2020, BY FAR,
AND THE PEOPLE THROW THINGS OUT,
ALL OF THE CANDIDATES THROW
THINGS OUT, AND THEY HAVE NO
PLAN TO EXECUTE.
WHEN HE WAS PUSHED ON HIS
BUYBACK PLAN, THE SECOND THAT HE
WAS ASKED HOW YOU WILL DO IT, HE
SAID, WE DON'T KNOW HOW WE ARE
GOING TO DO IT, BASICALLY SAID
THE SAME SIDE, I WALK INTO MY
HOUSE AND GO GRAB THE AK-47.
>> Jesse: NOT A GREAT PLAN.
>> Dagen: I WANT THE LEFTIES
TO GET CALLED OUT AS IMMORAL TO
REDUCE THE STANDARD OF LIVING
FOR EVERY AMERICAN BY TRYING TO
BAN FOSSIL FUELS IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM,
NOT THE SOLUTION.
>> Jesse: OH, JUAN, THAT IS
TOUGH TALK.
ARE YOU GOING TO LET THAT STAND?
>> Dagen: IT IS IMMORAL.
>> Juan: I'M GOING TO GO TO
CHURCH ON SUNDAY.
>> Brian: MEHR BOOTED TO THE
EDGE.
>> Juan: IS HERE REVEREND?
>> Jesse: HE TALKS TO GOD.
>> Juan: IF WE CAN LIMIT
CONSUMPTION, WE CAN LIMIT
GENERATING THE CARBON DEATHS
THAT GO INTO THE ATMOSPHERE.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING WRONG WITH
THAT, I JUST DON'T SEE ANY REELS
ABOUT THAT FROM THE RIGHT, AND
THEN THE LEFT SAYS, YOU ARE
TRYING TO CONTROL ME,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RAISING
ASTOUNDING AMOUNTS OF MONEY, BUY
A TRUMP STRAW, THAT IS HIS IDEA?
>> Jesse: IT DOES NOT MEAN IT
IS GOOD BECAUSE IT IS AN IDEA.
SOMETIMES THEY ARE DUMB IDEAS.
AND YOU ARE FULL OF DUMB IDEAS.
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY GOES
VEGETARIAN.
>> Juan: THE WORST IDEA IS NO
IDEA.
>> Emily: ALSO HALF OF IT IS
THE DELIVERY, WHEN YOU HAND
THINGS OVER, I'M GOING TO
RETALIATE BY EATING TEN BURGERS.
AND A POSTER CHILD FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD ELITIST DOUBLE
STANDARD, WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY I
WILL GIVE LIP SERVICE TO ALL OF
THESE IDEAS BUT I WILL CARVE OUT
AN EXCEPTION FOR ME AND
EVERYTHING IN MY WORLD.
>> Dagen: AND THE CO2
EMISSIONS, WE HAVE DONE A BETTER
JOB THAN ANY NATION IN THE WORLD
QUITE FRANKLY.
WE ARE BACK TO THE '85 LEVEL.
>> Juan: WE ARE THE RICHEST --
>> Dagen: SO STOP TALKING LIKE
WE ARE NOT DOING ANYTHING.
>> Jesse: UP NEXT, WINNING A
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY, SOME
DEMOCRATS ARE BEING FURIOUS
AFTER BEING CUT FROM NEXT WEEK'S
DEBATE AND RIPPING THE DNC OVER
THE PROCESS.
>> SETTING THIS REQUIREMENT THAT
YOU HAVE TO BE POPULAR OR FAMOUS
IF YOU ARE QUALIFIED, TO ME THAT
DOES A DISSERVICE TO VOTERS.
SO, I THINK THAT WE CAN RAISE
OUR VOICES TO CALL IN THE DNC TO
BE MORE TRANSPARENT AND REASSESS
HOW THEY ARE CHOOSING WHICH
POLES THEY ARE USING.
>> NO ONE HAS RUN A POLL OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMUNITY
WOULD ACCEPT FOR FIVE WEEKS.
I DON'T HAVE TO CHANGE ANYTHING.
>> Jesse: SO JUAN, SORE
LOSERS, COMPLAINERS?
>> Juan: THEY HAVE NO POINT.
THE DNC HAS BEEN TRANSPARENT.
THE RULES WERE SET.
YOU HAD TO GET THIS NUMBER, I
THINK IT WAS 130,000 SMALL
DONORS, YOU HAD TO REACH 2%, I
DON'T GET IT.
BUT MOST PEOPLE WHO HAVE DROPPED
OUT, THEY DON'T HAVE A
COMPLAINT.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO REMAIN, THEY
ARE STILL IN LOOKING TO TRY TO
MEET THOSE REQUIREMENTS TO GET
IN THE OCTOBER DEBATE.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE
COMPLAINING.
>> Jesse: JUST LIKE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE, DON'T
COMPLAIN AFTER.
>> Juan: LET'S CHANGE THE
RULES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: IT IS IRONIC THAT
THE BILLIONAIRE ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTIVISTS IS COMPLAINING THAT HE
CAN'T BUY HIS WAY ONTO THE DNC
DEBATE STAGE.
>> Dagen: $320,000 A DAY, ON
THE RETIREMENT.
HE DOES NOT CONTROL POLITICS.
>> Brian: WITH THE TIME THAT I
HAVE, I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THIS,
THE TOASTED GABBERT, SHE
COULD'VE GOT IN A MUGGLE AGAIN,
BECAUSE THE CRITERIA OF THE
FINAL TWO WEEKS, AND SHE GOT
STATIONED IN INDONESIA.
I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD SAY,
CLEARLY YOU ARE COMPETENT, YOU
HAVE A LOT OF IDEAS.
YOU WERE ON A ROLL, IF YOU HAVE
TO SERVER TWO WEEKS, I WOULD SAY
IF I WAS COMPETING WITH HER, I
WOULD SAY THAT YOU ARE BLOWING
THIS.
>> Jesse: THEY SHOULD HAVE
MADE AN EXCEPTION.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW, THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A CRANKY BABY.
>> Jesse: WE ALL KNOW,
BERNIE SANDERS, A LITTLE BIT OF
A CROTCHETY SOCIALIST GUY, BUT
HE IS TAKING THINGS TO A WHOLE
NEW LEVEL, WATCH.
>> I HEAR YOU CORRECTLY, SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE TO CUT YOUR PILLS
IN HALF YOURSELF?
OKAY.
WE CAN KEEP THAT DOWN A LITTLE
BIT.
OKAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: HE IS 100% RIGHT.
>> Brian: YOU CANNOT BRING A
SCREAMING BABY TO A POLITICAL
EVENT.
HE IS TRYING TO BE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
KISS THAT BABY.
>> Brian: QUITE DOWN, SHE HAS
TO CUT HER PILLS IN HALF.
>> Dagen: I WANT THAT DUDE TO
BE MY SIDEKICK AT EVERY
RESTAURANT I GO TO.
>> Jesse: THE BABY OR BERNIE?
>> Dagen: BERNIE.
>> Juan: HE IS NOT A I FEEL
YOUR PAIN TYPE OF GUY.
THIS IS SO RUDE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO SAY
ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: STICK A PACIFIER IN
HIS MOUTH.
>> Emily: HE IS SUCH AN
EBENEZER, WHEN IS HE GOING TO
STOP BEING THE FACE OF FORWARD
PROGRESSION.
IT WAS NOT EVEN 30 SECONDS, IT
WAS INSTANT THAT HE WAS LIKE --